welcome back to cbs saturday morning
from times square when major league
baseball hosted its field of dreams game
in iowa last month it was a celebration
of small town america but less than 100
miles away a small town is worrying that
its local economy that's centered around
baseball is getting shut out chris van
cleef traveled to caledonia minnesota
where a factory partially owned by mlb
is closing up shop and shipping jobs
overseas
that was the sound of economic
prosperity for caldonia minnesota a
crack of the bat that now rings hollow
in this slice of americana it's flag
line main street tucked between rolling
cornfields in the state's rural
southeastern corner this small town of
about 2 800 is home to the miken factory
that makes the batting helmets for major
league baseball and composite bats for
softball we're very proud of that
company a sense of pride about to be
lost pre-coveted the factory employed
around 150 paying better than a living
wage
now the roughly 80 people still working
there will soon be out of a job the
factory is closing and most of the work
being shipped to china it's going to
hurt the city
state they buy their groceries here they
eat food here or other restaurants in
town and now we're going to lose all of
that at the good times restaurant across
the street owner sarah glassroot fears
the news will bring her business
anything but good times miken accounts
for a quarter of her customers is it
easy to make up 25 percent of your
business no
but difficult before
pandemic hit it's even going to be more
difficult now but what really has folks
here crying foul is just who is doing
the outsourcing
once family run miken is now partially
owned by major league baseball after it
was purchased by seidler equity partners
and folded into sporting goods giant
rawlings seidler equity did not respond
to requests for comment the seidlers
also own
the san diego padres baseball team major
league baseball is going to see this
what would you say to them i thought
they'd have more respect for the united
states and small america dwayne
schroeder is caledonia's mayor that's
what they're after the buck it's just
not right and now to establish like that
and move that to china i think they're
going to lose a lot of fans mlb stresses
the batting helmets will still be made
in the u.s adding it owns less than 20
percent of rawlings and does not have a
role in the day-to-day business
operations the helmet work will shift to
missouri but most of the 80 jobs in
caledonia will be lost to china saving
rawlings at least 4 million dollars a
year i just keep thinking what would
happen if the commissioner of baseball
called up the guy who runs this company
and he says hey i don't think we should
do this minnesota senator tina smith we
should be expecting more of america's
past time than this kind of just you
know put the dollar first to kind of
thinking local officials are trying to
save the jobs and those talks are
ongoing but so far miken hasn't made any
changes to its plans that factory could
shut down in as little as 18 months i
think it's ludicrous
it'll be d slindy's job to help those
laid off find other work but she says
most of the nearby job openings pay less
than those factory jobs this becomes
kind of a talent drain because those
individuals that have to be making that
level of income are going to go where
the money is what does that mean for a
small town that's trying to
weather a pandemic and thrive certainly
a way to drain a community of its
lifeblood now one small town's field of
dreams risks striking out and turning
into an economic nightmare
for cbs saturday morning chris van
cleave caledonia minnesota
that economic ripple effect in that
small town you see no matter what the
business is like this so sad companies
have to worry about making money they
also have to worry about appearances
right so we'll see what happens here
national pass time it doesn't doesn't
that's the big thing it is
it doesn't feel right america's pastime